それでは本日カウンセリングとトレーニングと担当させていただきますと申します。よろしくお願いいたします。
お願いします。
ではまず今日の流れからご説明させていただきます。
まずこの頂いたカウンセリングシートを元にえっと池原さんの気になる体型とか姿勢のお悩みをお聞きするお時間大体
5分から10分ほどいいております。
で、その後今日姿勢診断が入っておりますので、後ほどお写真撮りまして、こうどう動かしたら体型とか姿勢が変わっていくのか、その期間のお話まで今日はさせていただこうかなと思います。
その後トレーニングに移ってまいります。今日体験ですので大体
種目ほどさせていただきましたらお着替えしてこちらに戻ってくるっていう流れになっております。よろしくお願いいたします。
お願いします。
はい。
じゃ、早速このシートを元にお話をお伺いしていきますね。まず今日ここの
IUを知っていただいたきっかけが
SNSで見つけてくださったんですね。
はい。
ありがとうございます。実際どんな媒体だったかとかって覚えてますか?
多分Instagram
で見つけたと思います。はい。
ありがとうございます。多分広告が流れてきたかなと思います。
はい。[笑い]
したら、えっと、これまでは今はピラティスタジオは今探していらっしゃいましたか?
そうですね。はい。
うん。あ、そうなんですね。かしこまりです。今日ピラティスは初めてですか?
はい。初めてです。
あ、そうなんですね。かしこまりました。じゃあ探していただく時にスタジオって結構たくさんあったと思うんですけど、その中でここの
IU
に決めていただいたきっかけってありましたか?
家から1番近かったからです。
あ、そうですよね。良かったです。ありがとうございます。それでは今池原さん抱えてる体型とか姿勢のお悩みがあればそちらもお聞かせください。
そうですね。猫背とか巻き型とかはずっと人柄も言われてて気になってます。
あ、うん。はい。
あとは背中とかの腕
はい。腕
お腹のお肉とかお腹の
下半身も
下半身もあかしこまりました。
ありがとうございます。じゃあ、あ、今気になる。その下半身は実際こう太もとかふハぎとか色々部位があると思う。どの辺りが気になられますか?
特に太も全体的に気になります。
そうですよね。太もってかしこまりました。全体的にですね。かしこまりました。ではそう気になり出したのはそれぞれつ頃から気になられますか?
背中とかにでとお腹も
はい。
この辺は最近ちょっと特に気になってて
下半身はもう結構前から元々気になってます。うん。
そうなんですね。
しくなりました。
じゃあ背中二の腕お腹は最近気になり始めたていうことですね。で、下半身はもう以前から元々太も全体が気になってるということですね。
はい。そうです。
しく終わりました。
したらその時期ぐらいもそうですし、これまでに体重の増減とかってございましたか?
ま、2年くらいで34km
ぐらい増えました。
あ、そうなんですね。うん。はい。困りました。じゃあその体重が増えた
年よりもその前の時って今気になってる部位とかってどうでした?気になられてましたか?
そうですね。下半身は結構前から気になってたので
うん。うん。うん。うん。
かしこまりました。じゃあこう体重の増減
でももちろんこう体のラインって結構
変わったりはするんですけど、ま、それ
以前よりも下半身が気になってたっていう
ことだと体重だけが問題じゃなくて普段の
体の使い方あと姿勢とか歪みから来たりも
するので今日をじゃあ私診断でしっかり
見させていただきますね。はい。はい。
かしく終わりました。
ではこれまでこう気になり出してからとか運動習慣何か取り組まれてたことってございますか?
そうですね。ジムに行ってました。
あ、そうなんですね。あ、すごいですね。いいですね。
ジムはどのぐらいの期間?いつ頃行ってらっしゃいましたか?
コロナより前に行ってて、コロナ期間で休んでたらちょっとかなくなっちゃう。そうなんですね。
じゃ、今日運動はかなりお久しぶりになられますか?
久しぶりです。[笑い]
じゃ、ちょっと今日頑張りましょうか。ました。
じゃあジム行ってらっしゃった時は気になってたところて変化とかありましたか?
そうですね。下半身も今よりはちょっとパツっとしたズボも吐けてたと思います。
あ、そうなんですね。頑張りました。じゃあしっかり運動習慣も以前はしっかりあったんですね。
そうですね。はい。
はい。頑張りました。
先ほどあげていただいた姿勢とか体型のお悩み全て含めて具体的にどのような体系になったら嬉しい?理想のイメージとかってございますか?
そうですね。お尻がこうプリッと引き上がって綺麗なラインになったら嬉しいなと思います。
綺麗。かしこまりました。じゃあお尻がプリッとした状態。あとは綺麗なラインを作りたいということで目指していきましょうか。おりました。
[笑い]
したらその理想の体型をいつまでに変えておきたいかご希望はございますか?
早ければ早いほど嬉しいだと思います。
[笑い]
かしこまりました。うん。じゃあどのぐらいで変わるのかって皆さんのお体のこう姿勢とかによってまた変わってくるのでそちらをまた後ほどお話しさせていただきますね。
はい。
はい。ではあともう
2つですね。
これまで過去に大きなお怪我とか病気、あとお医者様から止められてることって何かございませんか?
あ、特にないです。
確か困りました。は、ここの
IU
について今ご不安なこととかご質問などはございませんか?
はい、大丈夫です。
かこまりました。では今お聞きしたものを元にちょっとメニューを組んでいきますね。
はい。では姿勢診断に移ってまいります。
はい。
はい。はい。